should we recreate the scene where you
picked me up
although i have gotten a bit bigger now
you are a bit bigger we're running up
that hill and discovering all sorts of
fun behind the scenes moments from
season 4 of stranger things which scene
was completely ruined by someone missing
their entrance let's enter the upside
down and find out
number one
part of what makes vechna so compelling
is his creepy look you may be surprised
to learn that the stranger things team
created becna almost entirely with
practical effects one of the main goals
of prosthetics designer barry gower was
to create the character as close to 100
as possible actor jamie campbell power
had to endure a grueling prosthetic
application process they glued different
pieces of prosthetics directly to
campbell's skin how many pieces about
2425
the reason was it gave cambo more
movement than a rubber suit would and it
looked more natural the downsides though
aren't pretty it took about 7 hours to
apply everything and it was very hot to
wear so campbell would spend time in an
air-conditioned tent in between takes to
give him a slimy gross look he was
painted with glossy silicone and would
sometimes be coated with jelly another
unique part about becca's character is
his eerie void the broken house was a
real set they built on a blue screen
with giant red lights shining down put
it all together and you get some
seriously badass scenes
number two
eleven shaved head back in season one is
iconic but millie bobby brown wasn't
looking to actually shave her head again
for the roll this time around they went
with a wig for all of the flashback
scenes with 11. to get the wig on and
looking proper it took about an hour i
think millie is one of the longest
getting ready just because of her wigs
number three
billy is back well at least in a creepy
hallucination kind of way daker
montgomery was super excited to be able
to reprise his role as billy hargrove as
he showed when he was getting his gnarly
prosthetics applied even though he was
only in one scene it was a massive
challenge to pull off due to kovid
restrictions the solution was to have
him film all of his scenes separately in
australia while director sean levy
directed him over a video call that
sequence in episode 4 was one of the
biggest rubik's cube challenges of my
directing career this took place an
entire year after they had already
filmed sadie's sink scenes yet you would
be none the wiser watching the scene as
they blended the two actors performances
seamlessly
number four
the epic fight scene in episode 4
showcased how well the casting crew can
do action it was one long take so
everyone had to be on their a-game one
take was going particularly well and
seemed like it was going to be the
perfect run however when they got to the
very end one of the stunt guys missed
his q leaving everyone on set completely
perplexed after about a 5 second delay
the guy came barging in to do his thing
and thought he had nailed it and then he
got up and he was like i think that went
well if that was a bit by the stunt guy
kind of weird they eventually got the
scene done on their fifth take
number five
who would have guessed being a character
on stranger things would mean you have
to take golf lessons that's exactly what
charlie heaton and eduardo franco had to
do to prepare for one of their scenes
the scene has them hitting golf balls
off a ridge down into a junk pit so they
needed to have proper golf form they
went to a fancy country club and the
wardrobe department gave them very yuppy
golfing golfing outfits to go which
eduardo absolutely hated it's actually
super difficult just hitting it was so
hard like there's so much technique
luckily for them their shots didn't have
to be perfect as cgi was used for some
of them that shot's definitely cgi
there's no way eduardo hit that
number six let's go to the roller rink
millie bobby brown and noah schnapp had
a ton of fun filming their rinko mania
scenes they filmed these scenes at the
real roller king location in albuquerque
new mexico in their downtime milly would
place some music over the speakers and
they would go skating around the rink in
one behind the scenes blooper milly and
noah ran headlong into each other both
falling to the ground in laughter
honestly this week at the roller rink
has been a blast
number seven
it seems as if there is a lot of down
time on set during one of these times
milli and noah competed in the fruit by
the foot challenge wherein they had to
eat the gummy snack without using their
hands millie took the victory and
defended her title against jimmy fallon
when she challenged him
number eight
noah schnapp is known to be a big
jokester on set so when the opportunity
arose for millie to pull a practical
joke on him she didn't hesitate during
their last day of filming millie set up
a water balloon ambush with the help of
the crew at 4 am she called noah to get
him back to set and even faye cried to
ensure he would be lured into her trap
when he arrived he was greeted with a
barrage of water balloons according to
millie the assault lasted for a whopping
15 minutes
number 9
while filming a scene for the very last
episode of season 4 caleb mclaughlin had
to make a noise but it sounded sort of
odd it was supposed to be a panic scene
but the noise kept making his co-star
mason dye laugh caleb said it became a
running joke between the two which we
can only assume means the two would make
the goat-like noises around set
number ten
the scene of the kids in the pizza band
following eleven's roller skate
smackdown of angela is supposed to be a
sad and tense moment however jonathan
and argyle's antics in the front seat
had the kids cracking up charlie heaton
and eduardo franco improvised their blip
blip blip banter and every time they did
it the three in the back of the van
couldn't help but laugh
number eleven
when you're shooting a production as
large as stranger things you don't have
much time to sleep or eat that formula
made for a shockingly hilarious moment
during a night shoot in the middle of
the woods sadie sink decided to take a
nap when she woke up around 5 30 am she
was greeted by caleb and gayton chowing
down on full-size quesadillas in
complete silence as they stared straight
ahead sadie was bewildered by the moment
and couldn't get over the absurdity of
it all i don't know why
that just like i don't except it put me
over there
i'm going back to sleep it may have been
an odd moment for her but caleb stood by
his decision that was really good
number 12
it can get very hot when filming
outdoors in the summer heat so the cast
was really happy one day when ice pops
were brought to set for them to enjoy
the only problem was the ants not to
worry though because gayten had a genius
solution because you had this idea we're
like what if we made a trail of popsicle
juice
did it work
not exactly the crew just ended up using
ann spray and yet those popsicles were
totally worth it it was kind of a rough
day i remember but the ice pops made it
like
number 13
one of finn wolfhard's favorite memories
from shooting this season was a simple
one he was just happy to be together
with everyone the gang was very split up
in the previous season so when they were
mostly together right from the get-go it
was nice just being together was really
nice you savor those moments
number 14. this season of stranger
things was mostly filmed in new mexico
and lithuania the new mexico location
was used to recreate southern california
and the cast and crew loved it also
being in new mexico has been like so fun
for me it sounds like everyone had a
great time on set and that it was an
experience they will never forget and
we've had a blast and it's been the best
proof it sounds like everyone had a
wonderful experience working on season 4
of stranger things and their enthusiasm
and energy showed up on screen which
behind the scenes moment was your
favorite let us know and thanks for
stopping by at the things